with his own show the kids Super Show
where he basically has a bunch of comics
wearing the clothes it's not the
traditional models you know there are
santinos out there Stavros is out there
Theo Von was out there Jeff Ross Mateo
Yvonne Yvonne yeah she was great and uh
Harry he's a friend he's a French
comedian exactly you know Jay Balvin
came and did a joke like amazing yeah
yeah and then Tyra hosts it oh [__] yeah
yeah I knew Tyro was there and uh and
then I was on the show obviously as well
and then like like doing that and like
transforming what one of these fashion
shows can be like it was by far the just
the most unique way of delivering the
show yeah and basically when you look at
all these other fashion shows you
basically
trying to go what's the obstacle course
for these emaciated people to walk
around it yeah that's that's the
challenge it's like do they walk around
in nothing do they walk around on water
do they walk around in a house like what
is it and he was just like nah we're not
doing it with models we're going to have
these comedians go up there and how is
that son yeah
put it this way
outside of the show The the theater held
like 1300 which you didn't know I didn't
know I thought it was gonna be 50 people
yeah that's what I would have thought me
too so I was just like yeah I'm just
gonna make fun of this [__] in
front of his friends and like these high
fashion people and then whatever and I
found out the night before it's in this
beautiful [__] theater I was like oh
I gotta like write some jokes for this
[__] like this is this is going to be a
real thing that I got to succeed
we go outside of the [__] show before
it starts there's 5 000 people that are
trying to get into the venue oh the
police are called it's barricaded
there's fist fights in the street like
fashion fist fights which is hilarious
right like dudes with nails and [__]
scratching each other like it is crazy
okay they got a barricade the venue so
people don't go in they have to bring
down those metal things like their
clothes yeah he was like we're not doing
this [__] the venue's like we can't hold
this many people the fire department is
getting called [__] they thought the
show would get canceled for a second
because it was just so packed and then
you have to think like best case
scenario yes yes simply no one gets hurt
but yeah yeah that's for sure but
remember the people that you want in
that show are the writers from Vogue and
and from women's War daily and buyers
for all these places because you want
our boy to get the you know get the
press and get this and they're coming
from another show all over so they're
showing up and it's 5 000 people outside
most possible thing that could ever
happen yeah
before this show even started I was like
Mark it would be awesome if we all went
up and killed do you know it'll be
better
if this show never [__] happened yeah
because 5 000 people tried to break into
it and it was just absolute Mayhem it's
like well what is it why why is there so
much energy around kiss super
um they end up making the show happen
it's like an hour late which is also
fire like fashionably late boom boom and
uh Tyra goes up Tyra's [__] great all
the comics go on it's [__] funny it's
interesting it's different like Theo is
killing me bro girl like the
walkthroughs like everyone's walking
around in Theo it's just always Theo
it's amazing to watch it I don't really
hung out with them like like off like
watching them on like his bottom stuff
but he's just standing there and like
they're giving the walk through and this
guy looks like Yoda is like explaining
what to do he's like okay so you walk
around this these are like this and then
it just gets dead silent he just goes
like
so how do you even win
he's like but do you win like how do you
even get win the thing yeah they were
like no one wins and he's like oh okay
but he's just unbelievably funny yeah
you guys just walked like no so you walk
you walk onto the stage like a
traditional theater right you basically
walk to the middle make a right angle
walk to the front and then you do a few
minutes of stand up oh okay and then
after that you get off what was that
experience like
um you killed it so yeah it was fun it
was fun but like the the crazy thing was
not knowing what the audience was I was
like do these [__] speak
English are they
kids super specific fans are they
fashion fans like because I wanted to
make some jokes about fashion because
when will I ever have the opportunity to
do that like kind of specific nuanced
[__] yeah so but a too cool show
typically is not good typically but
that's why with the frenzy people got in
I think they're already more geeked
because
it's a hotter crowd and they're more
willing to laugh because like I'm gonna
enjoy this [__] that much more because
they couldn't get in and I could yeah
yeah yeah so it was good and there's
nothing fashion people want more yeah
than to be a part of the thing that
nobody could get into yeah yeah yeah the
best can I read something from Vogue
that they wrote on this yeah they wrote
on like The Comedians and their little
bits they wrote about Andrew the closing
act Andrew Schultz worked a routine
around Alexander Wang that was enough to
give a publicist recurring nightmares
so you guys heard of Alexander Wang we
got some accusations yeah so he was he
was basically like me too and dudes like
crazy yeah and it was funny like after
the show where they have to party and
there was a bunch of these uh these male
models came up to me and I know they're
male models because they called
themselves male models which is the
weirdest thing yeah like you could just
be like we model yeah you don't have to
be like we're male models yeah yeah I'm
like oh is that what gender yeah I'm a
male nurse
I mean I'm gonna add gender to
everything from now on are you a male
comedian I'm a male comedian yeah and I
was doing male comedy that night but uh
but yeah so I was like I was thinking
all right what's the joke about
what's a joke about like Alexander Wang
and I was able to like tie some things
in and like kind of you know whatever
but we'll probably post it it'll be up
soon whatever we'll get it we'll post it
and then um just doing some other stuff
so it was cool to do something that I
thought was like a unique set just for
that environment yeah that I kind of
never do again and uh and it was just it
was just fun and then at the end I had a
kind of like thoughtful moment for uh
for column it was kind of cool there's
like column used to go to the [__]
Louis Vuitton store in New York when he
was a teenager and he would sell his
shirts outside to the people waiting
online to get in and then and then I was
like and now he sells his shirts inside
that's fine and it was like you know
it's a [__] cool little moment for a
guy who's really awesome and has been
supportive of us so yeah but even if you
don't care about fashion I feel like his
story and what he's done like transcends
to where it can go into any industry
that's what I thought it was cool but
like I as a team too like he's got a
great group of guys I shout out to photo
like yeah he's got a what they got going
on kind of reminds me of what we got
going on man like it's really cool yeah
like even when they're putting together
a show I was like oh these [__]
don't have no clue what they're doing
yeah they're just doing it and I was
like yeah that's every project we've
ever done yeah yeah you know we're like
we're gonna make a special for Netflix
and then they're like have you done this
back man don't worry about it we gonna
figure it out but it's just cool like
fashion is so exclusionary and so like
no one can get in and like so too cool
and what he does is like opens it up
most of these fashion shows are like 100
people he's like 1300 people can come
here like fashion shows are like oh you
have to look this way and you have to be
this thing and you have to be super cool
and he's like nah [__] gustavros in
here yeah like it just it feels much
more open and much more like uh what a
shot to stop
I think he said it himself he said I
hold the record for the fattest person
to ever walk in Paris fashion yeah and I
think that might be true yeah that was
fun there was some there was some good
[__]